great well thank you can you hear me
okay great thank you very much Tom for
the kind introduction thank you to you
and Tina for the invitation it's really
great to be here and have the
opportunity to share a little bit about
my background and a few of my thoughts
about entrepreneurship I thought that
maybe what I do we have a limited amount
of time just maybe give a little bit of
background on myself my trajectory and
then describe you know try to pull out a
few of the lessons that I've learned
about building and leading organizations
that might hopefully be of some use to
to some of the members of the audience
so by way of background as tom said I'd
been very fortunate to have experiences
both in academia and in the private
sector I started my career as a
scientist a neuroscientist working on
how the brain develops during embryonic
and fetal development and also what goes
wrong in at the other end of the
spectrum in neurodegenerative diseases
like Alzheimer's and Parkinson's disease
where where nerve cells die I was a
faculty member at UCSF in San Francisco
and then recruited here to Stanford
where I focused on understanding
fundamental mechanisms of brain
development and degeneration but in the
course of this I was also very fortunate
being here in in the valley to interact
with people in the private sector and
got involved in a startup company as a
scientific adviser learned something
about that saw the power of the private
sector and then co-founded a first
company in 2000 Renault vus focused on
neurological disease where I learned a
lot about applying scientific knowledge
to difficult problems like developing
therapies for poorly treated disorders
and that gave me exposure it gave me
some experience that got me interested
in applying fundamental knowledge and
then I was very lucky and fortunate to
be invited to go to Genentech as over to
oversee about two-thirds of the research
organization eventually I was in charge
of the entire research organized
and erecting about 1,400 scientists and
disease research translational medicine
and drug discovery for neurodegenerative
diseases but actually primarily for
cancer and immune disorders and also
infectious diseases in addition to
neurodegenerative disorders it was an
extraordinary experience there where I
really got my first taste of executive
management working with just
astonishingly inspiring leaders starting
with the the CEO art Levinson and the
other members of the executive team so I
learned a huge amount about working in
the private sector and and harnessing
the power of the private sector to
tackle major problems a number of the
drugs that we worked on in those days
have now been approved by the FDA for
poorly treat what previously poorly
treated cancers and also some immune
disorder so it was incredibly exciting
and incredibly fulfilling also but then
after I was there for eight years I was
again provided with a wonderful
opportunity to return to the academic
sector as president of a small research
university in new york called
Rockefeller University just biomedical
research just a ph.d program no
undergraduates PhDs and postdocs but a
remarkable place in terms of the
accomplishments of the University and
the discoveries that have been made the
Nobel Prizes that have been won so I
felt very fortunate to go there and be
back in the academic sector and I was
excited because I've always loved both
the fundamental research and also
applying that to the other sides and
there I reconnected with the startup
scene getting involved on the boards of
some sort of companies and then
eventually co-founding three years ago
denali as as Tom mentioned and then
about two years ago I was approached
about this position that I couldn't be
believed my my luck and again felt very
fortunate to have the opportunity to
return to Stanford where I'd been on the
faculty in the early 2000s and to rejoin
the community here with a passion both
for supporting our faculty our students
in learning and also in research both
fundamental and applied again I I love
and I believe in the importance of both
and also to be able to help the members
of our community who are interested in
taking their discoveries and applying
them to solve real-world problems so
that's the the some of the the
background just briefly and maybe I can
go through this quickly so we can open
it up to questions as I think about the
lessons that I've learned in in in my
career about how to accomplish what I
hope to accomplish there there's several
maybe five elements that are important
and and by the way I'd say if I had to
summarize it what really drives me is to
try to do great things with great people
in great institutions would be the short
summary that's what really excites me
five elements first and foremost people
and and and given time I'll just say a
few things you know everything always
starts with the people the people you
hire the people you you work with the
people you retain it's essential of
course to have a high bar to recruiting
and and retaining people you want to
work with the best of the best and you
have to work at that but every
individual has their strengths and
weaknesses and you know one of the
things that I've learned to my job is
it's really important to try to set
people up for success to really play to
their strengths while also giving them
the opportunity to develop in areas
where they're less skilled so really
it's about supporting recruiting and
enabling great people to create that
space for growth and of course in all of
this to be fair and respectful of the
people you work with I think that's you
know the really the the the single most
important pillar and everything that we
do in in in all of the work whether it
was in my lab where I had postdoctoral
fellows and students or later in my
executive positions its first about the
people but then next it's about the team
and
it's essential with any group of people
to work on building the spirit of the
team through communication and again
reinforcing the mutual respect and
encouraged creating an atmosphere where
there's mutual respect among members of
the team so setting a positive tone
establishing that mutual respect is
absolutely key people teams
decision-making this is something that
again everything I know I learned at
Genentech I like to say a big focus on
decision-making and all of us in our
lives whether it's in the research that
we do and our teaching whether it's in
starting a company or working in a
company we'd always like to make at
every turn the right decision
wouldn't we anybody like to make the
wrong decision no no I don't see any
hands so we always want to make the
right decision but very very very often
you don't know what the right decision
is certainly in drug discovery where it
can be you know 13 years from ID in the
laboratory on average - a drug approved
by the FDA many billions of dollars
there's huge attrition most of the ideas
you start with turn out to be the wrong
idea so often you don't know what the
right decision will be and so what do
you do if you don't know what the right
decision will be well the the what we
strive to do at Genentech and might
strive to do in my life going forward is
to if you can't be certainly you're
going to be right and you try to make
good decisions so I'm going to
distinguish the right and wrong
decisions versus good and bad decisions
so how do you make a good decision the
way you make a good decision is building
on the team of great people who you
empower and whose ideas you solicits you
have to create an environment of open
exchange you discuss the issue with the
very best minds that you have and and
then take the best information and then
try to make a rigorous have a rigorous
process of decision making based on that
not consensus often with the most
difficult issues that we tackle there's
there can be many different views about
what the best decision is so you have to
hear them all but you have to be
rigorous about it and and
pourtant lee once you've made the
decision provide a rationale if you
agree with the majority explain to the
minority why it is that you're going to
go with majority if you go with the
minority even more important to tell the
majority why you're going with the
minority opinion and if you go with an
opinion that's different from both the
majority in the minority and it's really
important to explain why you're going
with neither of their points of view but
a consistent good decision-making bring
together the best people and providing
strong rationale for why you make the
decisions tilts the probabilities in
favor of making the right decision
that's the theory that if you work hard
at making good decisions which is under
your control you're more likely to make
the right decision and by the way if you
have a clear rationale than if you
realize down the road that it was not
the right decision you're alert to this
and you can course correct so you have
to be ready to course-correct as well I
went into this a little bit for a while
because it turns out in a large
corporation we were making decisions all
the time about you know where to spend
ten million dollars 100 million dollars
there wasn't we didn't have the luxury
of pausing and and you know saying we
can't make a decision in in in many
cases actually any decision is better
than no decision you have paralysis if
no decision occurs so you have to strive
to make a good decision and be ready to
course-correct
people teams decision-making vision you
need a framework for making decisions
and I'll call that the vision a
philosophy a direction that you want to
go in setting up that vision you know
you decide we're gonna spend more time
on this than on that we're going to
spend more time on oncology than on
immunology why would you do that and
being very clear about that in your
verse in a university we're going to
spend we're gonna tackle these
opportunities rather than those
opportunities you have to have a vision
for that and again I'm a big believer in
the wisdom of crowds and surrounding
yourself with great people in being at a
great community like here at Stanford
and tapping into that clicked of wisdom
to try to identify the great
opportunities the great challenges you
should tackle and prioritizing them that
way we did that in the private sector I
did that at Rockefeller and here at
Stanford hopefully some of you have been
involved in the long-range planning
process where again we
tapped into the community fact we model
this a little bit on what happened in
the School of Engineering a few years
before under Persis to tap into the
community and again trying to get the
input and and then being really rigorous
about assessing it and being very clear
about why we're making the decisions
we're in the middle of that right now
you will all be the judges and in the
next few months as we continue
collectively to head towards a vision
but that is the model and that is the
approach and that's how we are doing is
here and I believe that it again it's
this is good decision-making and
hopefully by making good decisions you
ultimately make the right decision last
point people team's decision making
vision values I should have started with
values but I think it's also very
powerful to end with values as you
approach and everything that you do you
have to be clear about what your values
are and the values of your organization
are and maybe I can just end with how
people ask me well what are your values
and you know what are your your three
Vout
top three values or things like that I
like to divide them into three areas
personal values interpersonal values and
what I call action values and so in
terms of personal values what I strive
for is honesty integrity and personal
accountability so owning that that
decision knowing that you know if I made
the mistake that it's you know I have to
own up to it
interpersonal values respect
collaboration and compassion again
that's what I strive to to to live by
and action values optimism initiative
and tenacity an optimism of course what
I love about Stanford is that is such a
deeply entrenched value here optimism
initiative you can't leave it to others
to do things you have to be willing to
step up to the plate and finally
tenacity because nothing important in
the world gets done easily nothing of
significance get done easily you have to
keep at it everybody here in this note
room knows it but you can't say it
enough you have to get back on the horse
and you have to keep going so maybe I'll
stop here so we have some time for some
questions but people teams
decision-making vision and values
our five important pillars in my
worldview and how I approach my job and
again I feel very fortunate to have had
wonderful experiences at extraordinary
places with great mentors and very
inspiring leaders that I could learn
from and who modeled great
decision-making and and great integrity
and a real focus on serving the world so
thank you very much
[Applause]
what books have had a most impact on me
and why did i cofounded Olli
well I guess many many books have had an
impact on me I'd say the the most
important important formative time of my
life was when I had the good fortune to
study philosophy at Oxford for two years
and there there's a range of books both
you know an esoteric subjects you know
philosophy of mind things like that but
also in philosophy you know a number of
writers in moral and ethical philosophy
I think that's one of the the most
important formative times of my life
in recent times I'd say a book that I've
loved and I go back to time and again is
a book called the the art of learning
some of you will have read it by a chess
prodigy those of you who know the movie
looking for bobby fisher' it's about
it's it's this young man who had an
extraordinary career who really talks
about the importance of that his great
strength was not that he could do one
thing or another but he was
exceptionally good at learning and and
he talks about how to approach that and
how to constantly be learning and moving
on to the next thing so I recommend that
book very much why did I co-founded Ally
the I'm very passionate about
neurodegenerative disease where there
are no treatments today essentially for
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's Lou
Gehrig's and so forth I believe that the
time is right scientifically to tackle
those diseases our knowledge of what
goes wrong in those diseases the genetic
basis and environment a basis has
accelerated thanks to the plummeting of
the cost of sequencing which has made it
possible to identify many disease genes
and and zero in on the biology that goes
awry in those those fields this is not
an area that major companies are focused
on because there's so much progress
being made in other areas that are more
they're nearer
and more tangible like immuno oncology
for cancer for those of you follow that
that resource are being poured there
this is being neglected and it's a time
when I think we should be focusing on
this so that motivated me to get
together with some colleagues and to to
co-found Denali
yes it's very clear why Stanford
University's finest in the world
I'd like to hear your perspective on
what is the single biggest sort of
what's the biggest threat slash weakness
to Stanford I think the when you have a
so I I was on the faculty in early 2000s
and I thought it was the most
extraordinary place in the world and
that came back 13 years later and it was
even more extraordinary right it's
really quite astonishing to see which
just goes to show how great leadership
can take a place that's great and make
it even greater right that said with the
success that the university has had I
think that our biggest threat is
arrogance and complacency the belief
that hey we're the best you know what
could go wrong you know that's it's if
pride cometh before a fall and you have
to be where we have to be constantly on
the lookout for what what how is the
world changing what are the new
opportunities you have to be constantly
striving to improve it doesn't matter
how good you are there are things that
have to be fixed there are plenty of
things here at Stanford they're plenty
there things here that are amazing
awesome miraculous there are plenty of
things that are subpar and broken that
we need to fix we're aware of them it's
been you know this long-range planning
effort is has been great in giving us
lots of input from our community on
places where we fall short and need to
do more you have to constantly say yeah
this is great but let's keep going for
for those of you a certain age we want
to be avis not hurts right
who here understands that let's see okay
everybody's over about 50 I see you'll
explain to the younger generation what
you know that means but it's you want to
be striving you know that you're number
two now if you think that you're number
one you get it lulled into a false sense
of security and that's that's the
beginning at the end Oh another way
putting it in this business there's no
stasis you either move forward or you
fall back and you have to work hard to
keep moving forward yeah yes so how was
it different running of being at
Genentech and again at Genentech I ended
up being head of research I wasn't the
CEO but the the sort of some ways in
which it's very similar the ways in
which is similar in a great place like
Genentech as in a great place like like
like Stanford it's all about talent
management it's about hiring great
people and enabling them to do their
work that's true in the private sector
explore true in the academic sector and
that's the role of leadership first and
foremost is to hire great people enable
them to their work and yes also hold
them accountable right so those are they
that's what we do so in that sense it's
very similar in other ways it's very
different at Genentech it is a hierarchy
right um so I you know I was the boss of
1400 people at Stanford there are 2200
faculty but that means I have 2200
bosses right so it's not that I'm the
boss of 2200
but in the end so so in a sense at in
the private sector we would discuss
things I could at the end of the day say
you know what I've heard you all but
we're just gonna do it this way you
would never do that
right people who are great don't want to
work for someone who will just be
autocratic like that so in fact the
management smile is not that different
if you strive to hire great people who
you want to empower and you want them to
be independent and function as a team
you have to treat them the same way you
would treat faculty which is to say
you're the boss right I'm gonna enable
you to do your best work
we're team and yes I do have the final
word if if it's necessary but you never
want to do that
yes oh actually I should say it is
because of the team aspect in a company
you can move further along where you can
assume that people will come together so
you can if with strategic planning for
example you can go faster than any
university and university it's so
important to get buy-in from people in
the company you can get by and more
rapidly so I would say the rule of thumb
is what if you're doing something
strategic in a company you can do it
twice as fast as in an academic second
or an academic second you need to take
twice as much time because you need to
it's very important to get that buy-in
from the community so there are
differences yes oh sorry yeah so as
president how do i influence the the the
culture and how does optimism fit into
that I think with the it to influence
the culture first and foremost you you
have to be a full member of the
community right and so you have to
personal you have to love the community
I think and be part of it and you have
to go out and meet people and and get to
know them and then you have to set the
tone and by the way this isn't just me
this is a again it's a running a
university as a team sport right so I'm
just so blessed to have a great an
amazing team an amazing partner and the
Provost Persis Darrell who was head of
your your your school here and and the
whole executive team and it's really
just extraordinary setting the tone so
you have to know your values and you
have to project your values and that's
what we strive to do one of the things
that person I have done we we felt that
it was important to have additional ways
of communicating with the community so
we have town halls we had one yesterday
we're having another one tomorrow at
Porter Hall you're all welcome every bit
of the community's welcome at those I
have office hours to meet with students
and again I saw some students this
morning and on Tuesday who's just sign
up please sign up if some of you want to
come that's for students that the office
hours Town Hall is open to everybody we
have a we created a blog you know the
notes from the quad I hope you've had
the opportunity just type in notes from
the quad into your search engine you can
see you know we try to address major
issues but also minor issues and just
fun things that we've encountered in the
community I think setting the culture is
about knowing what your values are and
it's about interacting with community
and by the way it's bi-directional we
hear from the community we learn from
the community and then we try to work
together to move forward as a so so the
first question is my views on artificial
intelligence and machine learning I
probably know less about that than every
single person here in this audience so
just to be clear although it is very
clear this is the digital age right it's
called it's been called the second
Machine Age it's the transformation is
extraordinary and this is true thanks to
advances in data science and in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning of course is powering
artificial intelligence then or in just
a remarkable way I do think that it is
different I do think this time is
different I think that Stanford has an
opportunity to lead in this area not
just on the technology side but also
thinking through the societal impacts of
this so that we can augment and multiply
the beneficial impacts and mitigate the
the the downsides that will come from
this and also think about the moral and
ethical dimensions of the application of
those technologies there so I do think
that it is different I think that was
your question and I think it's it's an
extraordinary opportunity I would say
more than an opportunity in a case like
this where there's an opportunity for us
lead I think we have a responsibility to
lead as well with the the great gifts
that we have here at Stanford we have a
responsibility to get out ahead of these
issues and and do this work on behalf of
society in terms of alumni how can they
help stay engaged you know stay involved
with with the campus community and
and do two things tell us in leadership
positions you know sure what we're doing
well we'd like to know that not just so
we can feel good about it but so we can
reinforce that and that's the real
reason for knowing what we do well so we
don't walk away from it but equally
where do we fall short we need to hear
that from you so that we can try to fix
that and also stay engaged not just to
give advice to leadership to engage to
help the current students you are such
an extraordinary resource for our
current students and you were there
before right and and so you know what
it's like so please stay involved with
them as well yes in a research
organization the size of Genentech how
did you maintain that that's a great
question how do you maintain that and
the there are a few things there sir the
deposit the positive actions and then
the things you try to to beat back the
the but there are lots of things when
you have something that large working to
reduce bureaucracy is really important
and actually in an organization that big
with a lot of teams there would be so
many meetings meetings meetings meetings
right so we actually had to deliberately
have rules about meetings you can't have
a meeting unless it's clear what you're
going to achieve and who the
decision-maker is no decision-maker no
meeting because otherwise you could just
spend your whole day in meetings so we
have to do things to try to prevent
bureaucratic creep on the one hand on
the other hand we a combination of
bringing in new blood young people are
always sort of really stirring things up
on the one hand and and so it's really
important to do that that would swipe
Genentech maintained a postdoc program
very unusual in the private sector 100
postdocs you know to the 1,400 employees
very unusual certainly in the in the the
the biopharma sector to bring in that
fresh blood those new ideas and so on
and also maintained a culture of
discovery and publication you know the
same thing as in in in academia that's
that scientists are evaluated not just
by what they did on other projects but
what by where they
so those were some tools we had to
maintain an academic entrepreneurial
kind of so those are academic tools the
in terms of doing it at Stanford the
same rules about really try to push back
on bureaucracy and enable free people up
so they can focus on things the we have
a very entrepreneurial spirit here we
recruit people or entrepreneurial the
whole system so I think we that's one
thing here that we just have to in some
ways enable it take away the shackles
you know make it possible for people
through their best work I think that we
don't need a lot of stimulating you know
going to give people pep talks on being
entrepreneurial that's that's in the the
DNA of the the people we recruit here
there's question back there I'm a
student and I was like walking down the
street like University Avenue and then
you see still home dance on the street
and then you've been through medical
painful process and you just feel like
it's like a kind of like like at this
play or bobbles like everyone seems
civilized and super-smart but you feel
you want to change something but at the
same time you're not sure should I start
the public policy or something you're
not sure how do you change that and
what's your recommendation was if you
want to have a social impact how do you
go about it so so a few things you you
bring that spirit to whatever you do and
be respectful of the fact that whether
someone is doing fundamental research
that it's not obvious what the impact is
going to be or is directly you know
working to help homeless people or
working you know with patients in an
intensive care unit that all of those
are doing good in society so we have to
be respectful of the fact that that all
are possible that's number one number
two there's the opportunity for
multitasking so if you are doing
fundamental research and you want to
have something more tangible there's so
many service opportunities there's so
many people who could benefit from your
direct activity you know go work with
Habitat for Humanity on the weekend you
know there are many many opportunities
here in the commune
and then the third point is life is long
and lived in chapters so you can do
something for a while and then you can
change and do something else and then
change and do something else and you
don't have to always try to do
everything in each chapter of your life
so I think bring that service of that
that spirit of service and to the
community to the country to the world
and if it will infuse and try to have it
infuse everything that you do but don't
feel that you necessarily have to do it
all at once yeah maybe we can take two
more questions and I will have to go
yeah so sorry there's one back there and
we can come to the front here yes I
would love to hear about your view on
hierarchies especially in a place like
this where like a lots of young people
with IDs and inspirations and yeah just
stuff on their mind want to maybe share
it with you and how do you approach that
and how do you try to maintain a certain
level of hierarchy maybe and yeah so
what's like your hierarchy hierarchy in
in certain types of organizations is
necessary just for the proper
functioning of them but it should really
just be to grease the wheels and should
never get in the way of the flow of
information up and up and down right it
just should be sort of just to make
things easy so you know who the
decision-maker isn't and stuff like that
it's really important whether it's in a
big company or in a university to be
constantly reaching out to all layers of
the organization you know the management
by walking as it's it's often described
and so I hope that it's pretty clear
that I'm not big on formality and you
know so I hope that if you have
something you want to ask me you
wouldn't hesitate to just come up and
ask me and by the way sign up for my
office hours and be happy to talk to you
about it so very important to not have
hierarchy and interactions very
important to listen to people there's so
many brilliant people and there's so
many people have great ideas and so many
people have so many experiences that
it's important to hear in our community
you need to be open to all of that
yourself that decade yeah you're not
back at the students what do you wish
you knew what do I that's the title of a
great book isn't it si what what do I
wish I knew when I was 20 and if it's
not been written maybe I should write it
no damn it's already oh there's so much
I wish I knew I saw as a first
generation student I went to college and
I didn't know anything I'd never met a
scientist but I thought I want to be a
scientist and so the only thing I knew
is that boy if I work hard and get good
grades
probably good things will happen and as
a result I didn't broaden my experience
as much as I should I wish someone had
said you know actually getting a broad
experience and learning lots of
different things would be really
valuable to you in the future just
learning more physics you know might be
useful to you as a physicist but you
know life is long and you may not end up
being a physicist check you know I
didn't end up being a physicist so I
wish that people told me that I wish I'd
known that what I said earlier life has
lived in chapters I was you know I was
the most hyper anxious undergraduate
you'd ever meet about my future oh my
god I have to plan out the next 50 years
of my life do not plan out the next 50
years of your life okay think you do
have to think out you have to be you
have to be intentional about it but you
know you're going to it almost certainly
almost certainly what you think you're
going to do for the next several years
is not port you're gonna be doing 15
years from now probably not even 10
years for now possibly not even five
years from now and that happened to me I
I was certain everyone to be a physicist
but then I got exposed to biology and I
had the opportunity to study philosophy
so I studied philosophy and biology I
became a neuroscientist when I started
at UCSF my life I always want to be a
research scientist I was so happy you
told me 12 years from now you'll be a
biotech executive I would have laughed
when I started at Genentech we said
eight years from now you'll be president
of a research university I would have
laughed when I started at Rockefeller if
you'd said five years from now you'll be
head of a comprehensive university with
undergraduates and professional schools
that I said forget it you know because I
I was not thinking about those things I
just as I had had the great good fortune
of working with amazing people and
getting great experiences I it opened my
mind to things that
didn't know I liked I changed the world
changed I gained experience things that
I was excited to do for a while I
realized that I I was now excited to try
something else
so keep an open mind and and by the way
the pace of change of the world is just
accelerating so this was true for me in
a career that started you know 30 40
years ago it's even more so for the the
students are gonna set out today that
the pace have changes rapidly so keep an
open mind listen watch how the world
changes listen to yourself right listen
to your heart listen to your soul and
what's exciting today to you ten years
from now you may feel that you're ready
for something else be open to that great
thank you
[Applause]
you